okay I have 12 minutes where's the clock
there it is okay so first of all it's
great to be here and I want to thank
James for inviting me where is James
Darius you'll hear from him later what I
want to talk about today briefly is this
sort of hybrid world that I live in give
you a little background about my
childhood I grew up in Manhattan I'm a
city kid and spent a lot of time going
to the Bronx Zoo and the Museum of
Natural History whenever I would look at
these official versions of the history
of Natural History I was always very
aware that there was a story that wasn't
being told about how humans have
interacted with the rest of nature on
this planet so to make a long story
short I'm going to talk about how I've
tried to cope with that information and
make paintings and images about a kind
of irreconcilable tension between humans
and the rest of nature obviously this is
an image of you know enormous power
everywhere that I've been in my travels
and I do a lot of traveling for my work
with my family which is made it a lot
easier over the years My partner sitting
in the audience is to go to places that
seem to be under certain amount of
stress which is pretty much everywhere
including Antarctica Tasmania Madagascar
and see for myself some of the impact
that humans have like finding dandelions
in Tasmania so on and so forth so what
I've tried to do is make a body of work
for the last 25 years that deals with
these ideas I use a lot of inspiration
from the history of Natural History I've
worked with scientists on projects Tom
Lovejoy it's big inspiration he's in the
front row right here Stephen Jay Gould
Peter Ward so on and so forth these
people I looked up to as being basically
storytellers about what is really going
on and this sort of unofficial version
of in the real version of how humans
have impacted this planet let's see if I
can get this to go forward there we go
so obviously you can see the enormous
impact that humans have in terms of
warfare but I also want to point out
that when humans wall stout of Africa I
don't know a million years ago or so
800,000 years ago wherever they went
they created extinctions Australia North
America so on and so forth this is
actually from Chesley bond Estelle's
painting right after World War Two it's
not of a nuclear explosion in Manhattan
but it's part of a cycle of imagining
the unimaginable this is a meteor impact
in lower Manhattan he also did a cycle
of images that have to do with how
nuclear explosions would affect the
great cities of the world these are ways
and Chesley bonus toe is one of the
great astronomical pain or visionary
painters of the 20th century who worked
in the film industry as well as well as
working for NASA made images about space
before it was possible to go into space
to sort of show what was going to happen
in a scientifically informed way this is
another way that we look at the history
of the world the top images of the polar
ice caps in 1979 and the bottom one I
can't see it says 2000 treat it 2,000
old we're close enough anyway you seeing
is believing unfortunately there's you
know a laundry list of images but one of
the things that I'm fascinated by is how
humans have to have a disconnect with
these images what are the implications
of this stuff obviously it's terrifying
but what does that mean in our daily
lives and how does that interact with
our culture I still think it hasn't been
reconciled and I'll show you a couple of
images that have to do with you know
parts of the way that these ideas and
images have entered into our language
but I still don't think we
the implications are obviously there's a
lot of attraction this being the week of
the Titanic sinking centennial the
failure of technology and obviously
humans having a sense of their own
technological expertise and the reality
of the situation obviously the history
of civilizations on earth are you know
littered with situations where humans
have mysteriously disappeared well it's
not so mysterious once you look at the
resource equation and obviously our
relationship to food and how we digest
pun intended the information about where
food comes from is still very much
mostly swept under the rug the same
thing with with where power our power
comes from in terms of carbon obviously
wars are waged on behalf of these ideas
and you know they're there they're
wrapped up in nationalism and all sorts
of other dynamics that I don't want to
go into obviously the history of hunting
and colonialism has a big impact on this
stuff as well so these are some of the
things that have affected our
relationship to the planet and you know
I think science does a fantastic job
that the the greatest job in the history
of human activity of telling the story
but because we're visual species I think
we have a hard time visualizing these
these ideas i'm going to give you a
little bit of a roundup of some
scientific images that have been a big
inspiration to me then i'm going to show
you some of my own paintings this is
painting by charles our night from the
field museum of early life on it looks
like algae mats on the lower right
obviously here's nights late 19th
century version of Apatosaurus when it
was believed that they were aquatic
there's Niles Eldridge's wall of
biodiversity at the Museum that's now
about 15 years old and he's been a big
influence on me over the years obviously
ideas about extinction have entered into
our popular imagination this I believe
is the KT impact hitting Chuck Shalhoub
and then of course human ancestry this
is a reconstruction by Viktor Deak of
Australopithecus which is a Photoshop
sculpture hybrid and again we have a
Chesley bond Estelle image there was a
big inspiration for not only the space
program but also destination moon george
pal's 1950 science fiction movie
scientific illustration this is a SARS
virus escaping a human cell and
reproducing these are all things that
have been a big influence on me as well
as some more popular culture visit from
Planet of the Apes we won't go into the
geology of the Pacific Northwest and
Manhattan schist the abysmal day after
tomorrow a squandered opportunity if
ever there was one and soil and grain I
think the poster may be better than the
movie but that's in case those those of
you that aren't familiar with them that
what Soylent Green is sailing green is
people and then another and i say this i
have some affection for for these movies
i think actually planet of the apes is
brilliant but this is from i am legend
as well as this and you know i think
that there's more care that goes into
these images and you know digital set
extensions and stuff then go into any of
the ideas and them which is a big
tragedy because why not spend an extra
couple of weeks you know working on the
script once I've put my finger in the
film industry and I kind of understand
why in a certain level now but it is i
think a squandered opportunity if ever
there was one whoops sorry about that
now we're going to show some of my
paintings if if we can get to them here
we go alright so the way of trying to
cope with some of these I
these irreconcilable tensions over the
years is to make paintings about the
history of knowledge this is a painting
I made 20 years ago called evolution and
it's an encyclopedia of some of the life
on Earth in the history of life it's 24
feet long ideas about the GMO Revolution
and the history of artificial selection
you can see it going from left to right
I'm also fascinated by the history of
you know art history obviously the image
before is heavily not only you could say
influence its quoting not only church
but the dioramas that we were looking at
earlier you know the Akeley Hall the
Field Museum the great tradition of
looking at nature which of course
whenever I go to a natural place now I'm
secretly disappointed that it doesn't
look like a diorama and it's very it's
embarrassing and also the history of
American Art in terms of we were looking
at peel and that's someone that
definitely is the great great
grandfather of an image like this this
is an image that comes from let's say in
less of an art historical context it's
not except for the sort of 1940s Rothko
look it's also from the golden field
guide of amphibian evolution so is this
collision between these two seemingly
disparate interests this is more foghorn
leghorn than real farm but it's I mean
all kidding aside it is I mean I had a
great time making it and was laughing
all the way but it was also a way to try
to show that the ideas of what a species
is and what the be she's boundary is
very arbitrary and what is appropriate
behavior and what isn't in terms of
taking genetic information from one or
the other and I have a lot of
ambivalence about those issues I did a
cycle about the biosphere two in Arizona
in 1992 to 95 which imagined not only
the biosphere in Arizona but it was also
taking it into outer space not well
actually in the solar system not unlike
silent running
trembles 1972 eco sci-fi feature so
ideas about time capsules and the arc
and and so on and so forth have been
fascinating to me and this sort of the
hopefulness of gestures like that this
is another image that's somewhat of an
encyclopedia these are some animals that
I observed in Guyana with Mark who's
going to be speaking later when we went
to Kaieteur Falls this is a 16-foot
painting many of these paintings are
very very large this is 16 feet so this
is really an encyclopedia of a specific
ecosystem in Guyana this is a 22 foot
mural in the Department of Fisheries in
Seattle's lobby that is a history lesson
in a geography lesson of some of the
most notorious extinctions in Earth's
history from humans leaving central
Africa to avian malaria so some of these
projects I set aside months to do
research for or read or talk to
scientists others are more intuitive but
they all have a foundation in the
scientific ideas and Natural History
this is from a project where Dorothy and
I went to Madagascar to look at some
lemurs and see some remaining forests
and then in the Northeast and I was
commissioned by the Lemur Conservation
Society to make an image that told the
story of what was happening there on
some level and we eventually turned this
in this image i modified it slightly
this is a painting that's now in the
lobby of the US Embassy in antananarivo
and I couldn't resist showing proof that
I was actually there there's a brew
kezia chameleon one of my very favorites
that obviously is very good at
camouflaging itself in the leaf litter
that was a particularly nightmarish hike
by the way here's purely fantasy
somewhat of a self-portrait
contemplating or nearest ancestor
Australopithecus this is a painting that
I actually just showed in New Orleans on
the left or invasive species that come
from all over the world invading a bayou
swamp in Louisiana and they're facing
off against endemic species of the
American South here's imagining
different climate change scenarios in
Central Park there's a street around the
corner from my studio there's a long
story that I won't go into for this I'm
rushing ahead a little bit because I see
my time is almost up ok that's pretty
self-evident you have a snakehead China
orientalis in the center there kudzu and
the life cycle of a Asiatic tiger
mosquito you can't really see it in the
in it but it's in there a couple of
climate drawings these are big oil oil
drawings on paper that are about 55 x 70
or 80 or so on and so forth and then
manifest destiny which I spent many many
volat TSA's say a long time on that
imagines climate change affecting
Brooklyn looking east and I worked with
James Hansen at the good art institute
on some of the data for this and this
this I this took many many years to
formulate it took about a year to paint
but it's 24 feet as well here's a detail
so i guess in a lot of ways i make
history paintings about bad news and
anticipating a future that might be a
little bit of a challenge so thank you
very much